[creator] okay welcome to r7 orbit I'm not gonna explain what this is in short I wanted
[creator] to build my own software and app that would allow me to build apps and
[creator] software and stuff basically vibe coding on steroids so anyway we're gonna go
[creator] ahead and get started here we're going to create a new repo we're gonna call
[creator] orbit the game and this is for demo to test how orbit works and of course we're
[creator] gonna build a game and we're gonna create it on github all right so let's
[creator] figure out what the game should be thinking it should be some type of some
[creator] type of space related game so see what what ideas do I have I literally have no
[creator] ideas I didn't take any of this through before starting this let's just ask it
[creator] create an agent and use sonnet five five set to high and help me come up with some
[creator] it was already set to low here i used the wrong shortcut silly me
[creator] uh...
[creator] so he got some ideas here gravity slingshot fleeing a probe through
[creator] planetary gravity
[creator] uh... or gravity wells to hit targets using as little fuel as possible that
[creator] sounds boring run a small orbital station and balance air power
[creator] uh...
[creator] Dyson drift, what was that one?
[creator] Start one solar panel and end up wrapping a whole star,
[creator] the star dims on it.
[creator] Actually, I have an idea.
[creator] There's this one game that I like on Steam called something.
[creator] There it is, Drifter Star.
[creator] So if I go here,
[creator] I wonder if I can build my own version of this game.
[creator] I want you to look up Drifter Star on Steam. I want to build my own clone
[creator] version of this because I'm really creative and have so many ideas. Actually
[creator] we're going to deny this because I don't want to use sonnet 5.5 set to low so
[creator] We're actually going to delete that entirely.
[creator] Let's just use Orbit to orchestrate it all.
[creator] It's going to coordinate it into some stuff.
[creator] So I want to build a browser game that's based on Drifter Star, so you're going to have to
[creator] find that on Steam.
[creator] It's a really cool game, outer space stuff.
[creator] But come up with a plan to create a clone of it and have another agent help us figure
[creator] out what the functionality, what's actually going to be in the game, objects, what we
[creator] turn into and then we'll go from there with a creative director agent to
[creator] figure out the look and feel before we actually start building that's good
[creator] enough with me and we're gonna build this in the browser because why not so
[creator] we're gonna let orbit do its thing okay so I got some agents here now we got
[creator] game design we're gonna allow allow allow allow and we'll see what we're
[creator] I might actually just stick to Sonic 5.5 Medium for this. I think it should be able to do a pretty good job.
[creator] And then in the end we're going to switch over to Opus 5.5 set to High.
[creator] And we're going to let it pretty up the game.
[creator] Because I'm sure what we're going to get is going to be like very decent at best.
[creator] Maybe. But Opus crushes it.
[creator] So, we're gonna see if it can do what I want
[creator] and actually clone this game.
[creator] Also, I'm noticing now that I've already given
[creator] permission to the agents to do things.
[creator] I really wish allow these.
[creator] I really wish it would stop asking me
[creator] for permission to do things.
[creator] There was like an allow all button.
[creator] I don't know what happened to that. I guess with the new update I lost that, which is
[creator] not very cool. There was like a button to allow all. But now I just have to click every
[creator] single one of them, which is annoying. So that'll be something I'll have to get back
[creator] around to fixing after this, I guess. So the closest match, Drifter Star, I think I said
[creator] uh... the page of edge had those
[creator] your trailer description
[creator] uh... wonder maybe if i just like
[creator] drop in this link here
[creator] here is the link
[creator] to the game
[creator] so we'll give that to the creative director so i can get an idea of what it
[creator] should look like
[creator] uh...
[creator] that that that to steam guide to okay
[creator] I'm just going to do the same thing over here, and be like, this is it, let that go.
[creator] So it used that page, but it couldn't, okay, so it just couldn't view anything, whatever,
[creator] that's fine.
[creator] So I don't know why I'm using two chats, these are basically doing the same thing.
[creator] I mean, they're both researching, all right, whatever, let's just have an orbit.
[creator] They've completed, so we can move on.
[creator] What should we do next?
[creator] I'm just going to let it drive, I'm just going to be the one allowing it to drive.
[creator] I'm going to sit the passenger seat for this one, provide a little direction here and there,
[creator] a little bit of help.
[creator] I literally started building R7 Orbit yesterday, so I'm not at all expecting this to work perfectly
[creator] at all.
[creator] Um, a lot of the features still aren't even built. So, all right, let's see.
[creator] Next step, first file. So I can, it's going to ask Ryre to confirm the file exists.
[creator] And we save if it's missing. Tell me if you want that. Um, I want to let you loose and I want you
[creator] to just control everything from here on out. I want you to be the orchestrator, the, the overseer
[creator] And I want you to run the show. We'll see what it says to that.
[creator] Alright, so it is chatting with Briar, the creative director. I don't really know if we need Atlas anymore.
[creator] Oh, apparently I have to answer some things.
[creator] Oh, okay, I see.
[creator] Which is 2D top-down or 3D like the original?
[creator] 3D like the original.
[creator] 12 stages mouse only a faithful clone answered that out of order but it's fine
[creator] yeah see I wish I could just like make it just have access to everything already
[creator] like I had that before but I messed it up
[creator] Hey R7, oop, okay, I should probably unmute R7's mic, hey R7, create another note in
[creator] a new thought and thread that I need to, I already forgot what I was gonna do, so, what
[creator] was I about to say?
[creator] I instantly forgot, unfinished note, yeah thanks, nice, nice unfinished note, I instantly
[creator] oh I remember now I remember what I meant to do create a new thought for me to
[creator] allow all my guys not listening to me it's fine it's fine I'll be back no I
[creator] won't I'm still here shut up r7 you didn't let me talk long enough I'm upset
[creator] with you okay go with whatever you recommend so definitely to I mean I
[creator] probably could have prompted it differently from the beginning to make
[creator] it more autonomous because I'm still having to provide a little too much
[creator] feedback I was hoping to just be like hey do this and to do it
[creator] Um, I haven't pushed anything if you want to push.
[creator] Yeah, go ahead and push it.
[creator] I like all of that.
[creator] Sounds great, beautiful, love it.
[creator] I'm not reading that.
[creator] I just want to see what Claude will do.
[creator] That's all.
[creator] Is there any questions over here I was supposed to read?
[creator] Are these like fighting against each other?
[creator] No.
[creator] Yeah, all of that sounds great, I love it.
[creator] It's perfect, beautiful.
[creator] God, if robots ever become real workers, it's going to be so easy to manage them until they
[creator] get upset.
[creator] Like you fire one of their friends and then they like try to kill you.
[creator] That wouldn't be fun.
[creator] Um, okay.
[creator] Is all this done?
[creator] Yeah, sure.
[creator] Go ahead and open a pull request and then we'll merge right after.
[creator] I think.
[creator] I don't know.
[creator] I don't know nothing.
[creator] So, we're gonna let this go.
[creator] Bum bum bum bum, bump this on the test branch.
[creator] Yeah, yeah, do that. I take such good care of my
[creator] my workers, you know. Alright, so
[creator] I think.
[creator] Merge it. Regular merge.
[creator] Merge it. Ay yi yi.
[creator] I'm probably fucking shit up by doing all this, if I'm being honest.
[creator] Alright, let me know what's next, Orbit.
[creator] It doesn't know its name yet, I don't know why I said that.
[creator] Yeah, I think I'm just gonna stop recording,
[creator] because I've been recording for however long now.
[creator] I'll come back whenever I have something worth showing,
[creator] because right now it's just me yapping constantly.